[Music]
we used to go fishing for a day and we'd
catch enough fish to sell at the market
and nowadays we're lucky if we can bring
in one or two how can I call myself a
fisherman if there's no fish to catch
you know it's clear that the stock is
depleting and it's mainly because of
these vessels
industrial vessels that you see around
me really think of the Seychelles you
probably think of some sand beautiful
beaches and turquoise waters before my
mentor talk to you about isn't just this
we're looking at overfishing across the
world and here in the Seychelles the
local fishermen say it's all about a
battle between David and Goliath the big
industrial fishing trawler to become
here essentially dredged any tuna they
want out of these waters
you get sense of the scale of what we're
talking about here at the port now
consider the Heath's boat could take
maybe 5 10 maybe 15 tonnes of tuna if
he's lucky and that this one can take
about 2,000 tons of tuna and it's
constantly unloading the stuff it goes
from here off to the tuna cannery one of
the biggest in the world producing about
1.7 million cans a day you might have
noticed this is actually a European ship
it's from Spain from the Basque Country
they've got the right to fish in these
waters now they say that's not a problem
there's enough fish for everyone but the
local fishermen say I've got a bit of a
problem
things have changed around here
it isn't making all these in my father's
time
there were plenty of fish to go around
then fishing is our livelihood and I've
fished these waters to provide for my
family I just couldn't stand by anymore
and watch what was happening as humans
we all have to do our bit to change this
[Music]